what's something you like to see wb do
warner brothers do that you think would
make the dc eu the dc
universe better
bring back lex luthor what um
say what it did bring back lex lizards
no i know did they bring back the
alexa that's the question she asked the
oh is that what you go by now the legs
no i don't go by that
some people do screen ran to other
publications
um a young gene hackman i always refer
to you as
by the way he's my favorite he was my
favorite lex luthor of all time so good
he was so good
but you don't know really that's a tough
question isn't it uh yeah i don't know i
i you know it's
like and this isn't just trying to i'm
not like i'm not definitely not evading
or dodging or whatever
um or or paying lip service
when i say i'm legit just
grateful that i get to be shazam
and get to be in that world and
um as a as a comic book
fan and video game player and lover of
all
nerdy pop culture like i have all kinds
of different ideas of i think of what i
think would be fun or cool
um but look i think that
from what i've gathered from my bosses
and conversations that i've had i think
that
that that warner brothers in dc are
making steps to do
exactly that at making it better i think
that you know there was
unfortunately just some mis steps or
misfires or
whatever uh that came in the initial
universe building that just didn't pan
out and
marvels did uh they took you know
i think feige and those guys were smart
enough to take john favreau
and robert downey jr's template uh
in the original iron man and eventually
just kind of
put that vibe over all of their titles
they realized that that's what people
want and they were right it's it's it's
just
it's funny enough and with just enough
action and explosiveness and death
but not so much that like kids are
freaking out and parents can take their
kids to the movie
like they struck the perfect chord and
favreau and
and downey did that first and then they
used that template and they did it
dc and zack snyder wanted to go the
other direction and be like let's
make this dark let's do it let's you
know let's do this this darker deal
and i think for batman that works i
think that
it uh was a difficult thing to apply to
all of the dc characters
because of their different personalities
and stuff and um
uh and ultimately you know they were
trying to figure out their tone and
zach had to leave justice league and
joss came in and now there's all that
drama and all these things that people
are talking about and that was all well
before my time and
i i don't i can't weigh in on any of it
but what i can say is that
now because the universe build didn't
work i think in the way that everyone
wanted it to they have they have pivoted
and now they're allowing it to be
this um multiple ver universe
uh dc universe the the multiverse
which now which is interesting because
marvel is now kind of doing that thing
as well but it allows you to to make all
the movies you want and they can be
connected or not connected
or whatever and i actually i think
that's smarter